so recently I was on a flight getting
back from LA to Dallas and I walk up I
got my wife and kids and everybody here
with me and then the flight attendants
tops me okay you look like in his late
50s early 60s later on I find out he's
63 years old when he stops him he says
oh my gosh Patrick wait David I watch
all your content do you mind if I come
get you afterwards I need to speak you
for 30 minutes very specific I need to
speak to you for 30 minutes I said sure
so I go grab my seat I'm doing my
thinking and all of a sudden he comes
back and he gets on his knee and we
start talking he says you know I watch a
lot of your stuff he starts talking to
me about sleep you know then he started
talking to my wife and he started asking
I watch your episodes I watch it and he
is a meticulous student about heatoman
right so he says to me says look I got a
question for you how do you measure
success I said what he Ben how do you
measure success he says well you know
for me you know my son used to like to
play video games and a lot of people
didn't want their kids to play video
games so instead I went and bought a
computer and we you know Torro computer
down we rebuild it back up and then he
started working at Best Buy then he went
to Colorado and then he started working
at the cybersecurity company and my wife
and I were stockbrokers he's probably
watching this his name is Doug and my
wife and I are stockbrokers and we do
this but I do this part-time because I
worked as many hours and but what he's
saying is you can see like a part in his
eyes which is like you know you know the
movie Saving Private Ryan I remember the
first time I watched Saving Private Ryan
when I was in the military at the end of
the movie the guy the main character
Private Ryan is standing at the plot of
the man who saved his life and he says I
won't forget what you told me and he
looks at his wife he turns around says
baby just tell me I've lived a good life
tell me I've been a good man right I
almost felt that from his eyes when I
looked at Doug and he says can you
please make a video and elaborate on
this topic of how do you measure success
so today's video Doug is dedicated to
you I don't forget your request just
took me a couple weeks but I'm making it
for you for everybody watching this year
today we're gonna talk about different
ways to measure success and the message
is gonna be probably different than
anything you've ever heard of in the
past on measuring success
[Music]
if this is your first time visiting this
channel this is animal channel on
YouTube for entrepreneurs if you can
click over here to subscribe we got over
a thousand videos on how to do a lot of
things in business as well as a lot of
cool interviews again if you haven't
subscribed please do so let me get right
into it how to measure success so Doug
asks me Pat how do you measure success
look the way I view success may be
slightly different let me explain to
what I mean by this you see in sports
there's a lot of people that they call
triathletes or this person like Deion
Sanders played football and baseball
Brian Jordan you know football and
baseball bo Jackson same you know
football and baseball and you know
mahomes used to be a great pitcher 96
mile an hour pitch and he's a great
quarterback MVP last year and Casey and
in Hollywood they call him Triple Threat
Justin Timberlake and dance and sing and
act JLo all three Beyonce all three all
these people like oh my gosh these are
triple threats on baseball they say
Triple Crown RBI hits you know home runs
Ted Williams type of person and these
are what you call people that are great
at three different things or more right
in life if you look at Hollywood Wayne
Johnson may not be a triple threat
because he's never done a music video
well he actually did with the Moana
right he was singing in that movie but
dancing maybe he can do his dancing that
he does the Hawaiian stuff that he does
but you know what he's a wrestler and he
went to the top of wrestling he went to
the top with his body if you look at his
physique he's got an incredible physique
people look at his body he's got a
contract with Under Armour every other
week he's coming up with new products
number one selling product on Under
Armour he's known these are number one
promoter around the world number one
moneymaker on Hollywood 120 some million
dollars in a year and he's doing
businesses here in China they say 56
percent of the world recognizes his face
he's number one in the world by
recognizing his face how did this happen
he's a multiple threat so now let's come
to you let's talk about you here so what
does this mean to you okay you ever meet
people who have great marriages but they
see somebody who is worth a lot of money
but they try to you know kind of
undermine that person
in the area they failed in and kind of
glorified themselves in the area they
succeed and sometimes we all tend to do
this because we're insecure with
ourselves right do you think about like
oh my gosh look at that girl look at me
right if you're fully engaged in your
own life winning you don't do a lot of
them my biggest concern when you look at
this is when you explain how do you
measure success there are a lot of
people that are very successful in their
marriages you look at them think about
the most successful person you know
that's been happily married to his wife
and her husband and they've been married
for 42 years happily you look at them
you're like you guys ought to write a
book together how are you this happy
together we've we've been happy we had a
formula here's what we follow we always
did this how'd you do it but they're
broke but they're happily married right
and you look at somebody else and you
say wow look at this person here you
know he's made so much money for himself
most successful person you know look at
his physique what a body he's in shape
he does Ironman
unbelievable look at the amount of books
this person right
this person is incredible with their
work in their career they're the best at
their work oh my god she's the best
graphic designer the best writer the
best copywriter the best journalist the
best person in sports and whatever they
do the best backgammon player the best
chess player while this guy's earned
success in his life
he's a successful person right this
other person every time I want to get
ahold of anybody I just called this guy
he's got access to everybody on his
phone his rolodex is powerful you know
this other person is a great hedge fund
manager what a successful guy right so
you look at all this stuff then for you
the reason why I say success is
multi-dimensional is because of you a
lot of times when I see my peers or
people that I know or people in the
market place value Tanner's when they
talk to me they typically measure their
own success to others failures look how
happily married I've been Mikkel
miserable this guy's been look how rich
I am look out four years
look my body look a lighter shape this
guy's right instead for you my challenge
to you is becoming a triple threat if
not more some think you can't have a
great marriage and be in shape and have
kids and win in business and do this and
do that all of that stuff is said by
people that simply don't want to make
right now watch this you can't be great
at 50 different things it's not gonna
happen we were having a conversation
earlier today because the book that I'm
getting getting ready to publish we are
this close I am so excited about the
book I cannot tell you how exactly this
is the first time with the book we've
been working on for three years of
business book why look and I say I can't
wait to sell this book and share with
everybody the moment people read they're
gonna say this is this is gonna help me
out there was a wart I had a hard time
with I said I'm not comfortable with
this word why because I don't think one
person can go out there and be the
greatest at ten different things I just
don't believe that you can't do it
greatest I don't think somebody can be
great phenomenal best of the best and
five different things because you got to
be focused into one thing to do it very
good and typically when you do one thing
is very very good it typically bleeds
into other aspects of your life if
you're the greatest comedian you're
automatically gonna make a lot of money
and have a lot of different
opportunities that come your way and
your rolodex your phone book all this
other stuffs gonna get better and better
and better you're probably gonna get
access to the better trainers better
teachers better everything right because
you want so big in one level right once
you wouldn't so big out one of our other
places combo if you're watching this
question for you is the following and
it's a challenge for you can take it any
way you want take a close inventory of
yourself and ask yourself if you sit
there and mainly measure the area of
your life that you've been incredibly
successful at and discount the other
areas that you can put an effort in to
compete as well and you kind of make an
excuse to hide away from it now yeah I
don't know if I need to necessarily do
this part but look how great I am in
this okay look how good of a job I've
done in this area can you really make
the effort also to get good at a couple
different areas here or you're just
hiding in one area that's the challenge
to a lot of you now for some of you that
are sitting there saying I'm an Pat
after listening to this makes me feel
better about myself why because a person
like Doug Doug let me tell you something
to raise a kid who he will never forget
that his daddy played games with him and
didn't judge him and brought a computer
to entertain him and his son ends up
going and working at Best Buy and you
don't judge him and now he's working as
a cybersecurity person in Colorado you
ought to be proud of yourself for
personal like Doug that's been married
for 20
forty years he and his wife are running
a business together that's another
method of success so if you're the
person that's constantly measuring
yourself against others failures change
your mindset and challenge yourself but
if you're the person that's always
comparing other success to your failures
never forget that you also have won in
other areas sometimes Doug and people
like him you got a re remind yourself
other areas you wanted to inject
confidence in a new place that you can
also win because the track record the
clue that was left from winning in
another industry that formula is there
as well you just got applied to the new
place having said that I got to other
videos I want you to watch one of them
it's one of my funnest videos I ever did
it's called who to marry and how to
marry him click over here if you want to
find out about who to marry and how to
marry but there's some crazy stuff and
there were you gonna enjoy it while
watching this one here and the other one
is how to double your income both of
these videos have to do with people
watch and say man I don't know maybe
marriage I need to kind of get clear on
I'm single then watch this video maybe
your income is too long you want to
double it go watch this video either way
whatever one that you want improving go
watch these videos and again if you
haven't subscribed to the channel please
do so take everybody bye-bye